le proto bus c'est un bus non c'est pas
n'importe quel bus c'est un bus qui met
le proto 204 sur 4 ou pour aller engager
les innovateurs de paris saclay là où
ils se trouvent
là où le travail là où es tu dis là où
ils vivent et là où se déplacent le
proto bus c'est un projet qui est porté
par le pays apparaît sacré de la manière
qui porte le poteau 204 mais aussi avec
transdev qu'un opérateur de mobilité à
paris saclay et qui s'est dit que les
mobilités s'est aussi déplacé des idées
et à travers le proto bus savane une
coquille qu'on va inventer avec d'autres
partenaires pour engager les acteurs sur
le territoire il ya beaucoup de pistes
qu'on doit qu'on doit creuser et aussi
qu'avec sommes trois grands axes à le
premier c'est un lieu de créativité de
fabrication mobile tout simplement au
lieu d' événement un peu particulier
parce qu'avoir un bus comme ça aménagé
pour montrer des start-up montrent des
chercheurs contre l'association
eh ben c'est quand même assez
particulier et d'autre part c'est un
lieu de test aussi pour carrément des
innovateurs des chercheurs des points
qui veulent tester des projets et bien
que l'ail puisse le faire là où les gens
se trompent
le proto bus comme ça va être un sérieux
et comme tout bon tiers-lieux nécessite
des ateliers de préfiguration pour
savoir à quoi il sert est ce qu'il est
vraiment utile pour les acteurs qu'on
cible et donc on a fait le 11 avril une
première ateliers de préfiguration avec
une trentaine d'acteurs on a ciblé à la
fois sur la part des décideurs
industriels des collectivités et aussi
bien sûr des usagers étudiants
chercheurs habitants et ce qu'on leur a
proposées c'était pendant une
demi-journée d'être une bise nationaux
d'être avoir un commando comme ça pour
savoir est ce que le produit pouvait
vraiment leur servir sur les trois
scènes rock on a vu lui de créativité le
d'événementiel et lieu de test pendant
l'après-midi un travail sur ses trois
grands axes avec l'objectif de trouver
des solutions que le proto bus pourrait
apporter à des problèmes actuels donc à
chaque fois les plus actifs de trouver
des usages concrets et qui nous servir
comme scénario pour développer la suite
du projet après ce premier atelier aura
au moins deux autres qui vont permettre
de creuser petit à petit dit les étapes
du projet notamment l'aménagement du bus
à la fin on savoir qu'est ce qu'il ya
vraiment dans le bus et on espère du
coup comme ça au pouvoir après refasse
et la faisabilité lancée le bus et c'est
la fin de l'année 2016 et commencer la
première tournée en 2017 du proto bus
sur paris saclay